welcome back my guest tonight our two
seniors from Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in Florida who are part of
the never again movement a group of
students working for gun control and
school safety please welcome Delaney tar
and Carly Nobel you guys have been
through a lot thank you for being here
after a tragedy like this what are you
guys hoping the response will be I think
there should be legislation to give us a
step in the right direction something
small to start towards gun control I
think we've made it very clear that
we've been fighting for common sense gun
laws we just we want people to stop
getting shot with you want children to
stop dying at the hands of ar-15
semiautomatic rifles so we're working
towards more common-sense gun
regulations ya know you know I'm an
adult I've been through this no offense
but I put in my time I've seen this
before
and what Americans do is we think we
pray and then we move on wiser and well
at least wiser why are you guys mucking
that all up well as we've discovered
thoughts and prayers generally don't
protect you from gun fire
we're being given a platform and we have
a voice that is unprecedented the
victims of Sandy Hook of course were
children so it was the parents speaking
out and Columbine didn't have social
media to use as a platform but we have
those things and we're using them to our
advantage it feels like a fully for
movement already this is it feels new
though to most of America how is it so
fully formed gun control has been a
movement for a long time and now we're
all speaking out on it so we all know
about it and I think in the past few
days we've become more well researched
on it that's the problem all right this
is if I can give you one piece of advice
research is gonna get you nowhere
don't bring a well-researched argument
to a gunfight passions you fight over
symbols a gun isn't a gun it's a flag
that's how Americans want to deal with
guns we don't ever really want to talk
about guns guns are confusing and what
have you we want to talk about Liberty
and why do you guys want to take away my
liberty well we're not taking away your
Liberty actually and that's something
that we have tried to make clear time
and time again we're not taking away
anyone's Liberty we're not just
completely borrowing the Second
Amendment from existing that is not our
goal our goal is of course to let our
younger siblings to let our cousin's to
let the children that we know in our
lives to be able to go to school without
having their school shot up that is
ultimately that is our goal to make the
world safer to make our country safer
because this is an American issue and
we've seen so many other gun legislation
be passed through in other countries and
it has worked but is gun control the
answer wouldn't wouldn't more guns in
schools make you feel safer wouldn't
having a teacher who has an access to a
gun isn't that gonna make schools safer
that's going to school in a prison and
having your teachers be your prison
guards
they said in terms of that in terms of
metal detectors in terms of fences which
is just a strange solution to me
Americans love walls that much is known
we have said that those are temporary
solutions for a much bigger issue they
are the equivalent of putting a band-aid
on a stab wound because they don't
ultimately fix things it's just it's
will slap this on there we'll see how it
goes and that doesn't even work for
every school our school is an open-air
school so we cannot put metal detectors
arming our teachers we have older
teachers who are not capable of handling
guns we don't know if we'd feel safe
having teachers with guns because
students can access those there's many
ways that it could go wrong and we'd
rather then focus on something small
like that to focus on addressing the
much bigger issue of we have people
accessing guns that should not be
accessing guns we have people doing
things that should not be able to be
done also it's not even just in schools
you can't have a metal detector
everywhere you go we go out every day
and you shouldn't have to live in fear
of going outside well maybe that's the
issue you kids you want to go outside
all the time I was a kid I stayed inside
and I made a purposeful choice not to
have friends and I stayed in inside
Thank You Carly you've you got on the
attack you you Tommy Lehren posted
something online recently and you you
responded somewhat harshly which is
tough because she's she's fragile what
what what did she say that got you so
upset she told us we had to wait to talk
about gun control
when waiting is what got us to this
point waiting after every shooting is
the reason why nothing ever changes so
we're trying to talk about it right now
and keep talking about it until
something changes what when is the right
time to talk about gun control all the
time not not just after it students
can we push all the time back like a
month if you want a specific date to
talk about gun control if there are so
many people that aren't willing to
address it here's a date March 24th the
March for our lives that is an
unavoidable predetermined date to talk
about to address and to fully change gun
reforming gun control large 24th March
24th I'm gonna write this down and say
it so I'd know not to be there March 24
it'll be in every community too so it'll
be hard to avoid March 24 March 24 March
24th arts play I'll remember to forget
that date from Florida a lot of the
legislators in Florida have taken money
from the NRA to not push gun control I
have a briefcase underneath the desk
right now with $8,000 in it can be yours
all you got to do is drop this whole
thing
see we're trying to decrease the magic
of being bought out by interest groups
we're trying to make that the badge of
shame here because ultimately the NRA is
what is letting these things happen
because they are funding these
politicians they're giving millions of
millions of dollars and we want that to
be known we want the names of those
politicians we want them to know how
much money each politician is taking so
that they can know that they can do
better they can stop taking money and
that there is room for improvement and
we're willing to work with them on that
well I mean it's a it's a lovely badge
of shame it can buy so many things that
you might be into like digits spinners
tie pots
Delanie tar and Carlito Bell the fight
continues
[Applause]
[Music]